the duke and duchess of cambridge have
released two new portraits to mark their
10th wedding anniversary the pictures
were taken at kensington palace by chris
floyd
two billion people across the world
tuned in to watch the couple tied the
knot
in westminster abbey 10 years ago and in
the past few minutes the couple have
posted
this video on their twitter account
[Music]
in a tweet the couple said thank you to
everyone for their kind messages on our
wedding anniversary we're enormously
grateful for the 10 years of support
we've received in our lives
as a family let's bring in roya nica the
royal correspondent for the sunday times
now hello to you roy
i don't know whether you were able to
see that video as it came out
a private family video of uh william and
kate with their three children and i
think it's a norfolk beach and in their
uh back garden at ammar hall
what are they trying to show to us
here well i think
that's a really interesting release
we've just seen there and i think it
goes straight to the heart of
what has made cambridge is a very
successful family
in terms of public image because while
they jealously
and fiercely guard their privacy what
they're very good at doing is just
putting out just enough
photographs and now a video clip of
private family time
that makes the public feel they are
invested in them and they're getting to
see a little bit of that behind the
scenes magic and
that that like you said that video came
with a a message
thanking the public for all their
support over the last 10 years and i
think
what they're trying to do with that is
to say we understand
you're hugely interested in us and our
lives and our children
um thank you for you know respecting our
privacy and supporting us
and here's and here's a video giving you
a little bit of insight into what family
life is like
for the cambridges and we have in the in
the last couple of years seen
a little bit more access haven't we to
the family life behind the scenes the
children
uh being a little bit more prominent
does it suggest to us
an increasing confidence in in who they
are where they fit and what their roles
are
um yes i think so and i think that
as you mentioned the sort of growing um
access that we've seen
we we have um but what's always quite
interesting is that it's it's controlled
and
it is very much on their terms and it's
very often kate that takes photographs
of course chris
floyd the ones that came out today but i
think we are sort of seeing
um we know that william and kate are
taking on gradually you know
more work they are stepping up in terms
of their responsibility uh within the
royal family supporting the queen who's
now 95.
um and we are we are seeing a lot more
of them because
their you know their role in public life
and their role within the royal family
is becoming more prominent more
important
and this is a role that prince william
was born into
but one that the duchess has married
into how do you think she has grown into
that role and adapted and made it her
own over the course of the past
i decade it you're absolutely right she
has grown into it and
it has been a journey for her and an
evolution if you think back to
where kate was just after her wedding we
didn't hear
very much from her in those first couple
of years this first few tours we went on
with william and kate together
um it was william that did all the
speeches and and the
the public sort of uh statements but in
the last few years we've heard a lot
more from her
you know we've heard some very assured
speeches on her
her big topic she's passionate about the
early years in childhood development
we've had a couple of big keynote
speeches from her on that she is
becoming more confident
she is much more sure of the direction
she wants to go in terms of her work
um that is a role she has grown into and
to be honest i think it's one that
william is still
you know carving out for himself even
though he was born into it
and in terms of that role in the future
um that will become more and more
prominent
more important and it has been a very
difficult year leading up to this
10th wedding anniversary images that we
saw
after the funeral of the duke of
edinburgh
where and the role that the duchess was
playing between the two brothers the
feuding
brothers i wonder if we can get your
thoughts on that roya
um well i wrote a big piece on that for
sunday times where my thoughts featured
and my thoughts on that very much are
yes i think kate
uh you know played a diplomatic blinder
there in terms of just
um sensitively allowing the brothers to
speak um my understanding is that i
think
it was very much a united front uh for
the royal family to honor prince philip
at the funeral so there should be no
visual depiction of of um any disunity
but i think
that relationship between william and
harry is
has a long way to go in terms of ever
being back to where it was
um the oprah interview you know was a
bomb under the royal family
william didn't take it well no one in
the royal family did
um i think there's a long way to go to
heal that bond that was once so strong
between those brothers
it also leaves william and kate with a
lot of the workload to pick up the
departure of harry and megan who
potentially would have been sharing that
as the the queen scales back her duties
it does and i and i recently wrote a
profile for the sunday times magazine
actually exploring this very point and
people i spoke to
very close to william um that's a very
important thing for him i think he
definitely feels the pressure
um in terms of not having harry
by his side to share that responsibility
his his
future as someone said to me um he feels
looks very different now because of
you know what has happened because of
the decisions that they've made i think
he
is starting to accept that but it's
definitely been a big adjustment in the
last year
roy nicker always good to hear from you
thanks very much indeed for joining us
this afternoon